so angle of Medina Montes is going on
holiday with a campervan can be great
because you're free to stop pretty much
whenever you feel like it but handling a
campervan like this is quite different
to driving a normal car heimer offers
training on how to drive these vehicles
safely and Mathis has come to check it
out nameless I'm whom are fuzzy guides
training here in Northern Europe it's
certainly not the peak season for
campervan holidays right now but even
here many people like to get away from
the German winter at the socks and ring
racetrack professional instructors are
on hand the show drivers how to react
correctly in every situation and ensure
they drive safely the first
consideration is loading the vehicle
correctly
and love before mongols model gyres the
main instructor he says it's important
to look over everything once more before
you leave anything that can shift needs
to be stowed properly you need to draw
up a plan beforehand to ensure that
everything is correctly packed or
fastened down so it can't move
lengthways or sideways when tons o for
pesticides agonist laba vo in length
Salonika perished in konkan if the
driver has to hit the brake suddenly
items that haven't been properly secured
can turn into dangerous projectiles
[Music]
driving in a circle proves instructive
even for experienced camper van drivers
the participants practice a situation
where the driver has underestimated the
bend and approaches it too fast
[Music]
Susan thathe the instructor explains
that the road surface is slippery and so
you start to slide the mistake most
people then make is that they start the
steer more when you move past the
slippery part there is a risk of the van
tipping over so it's important to reduce
your speed and practice breaking
correctly the Splane since William
reacting and decisively or breaking
incorrectly can make the braking
distance much longer in some cases that
can prove fatal
often drivers don't realize the trucks
need a longer braking distance
participants watch a test situation that
demonstrates why it's important always
to keep enough distance when driving
behind a truck
a Venetian authentic but Martha says the
course doesn't just focus on how to
drive safely on the open road what
happens when you decide to stop
somewhere for the night if you park your
camper van at a campsite you often have
to negotiate your way past other outsize
vehicles there might be trees to avoid
as well and things that can start to get
complicated by slingers I've seen enough
and Papa lima often be y'all done thanks
Tuscan Sun Felix together during the
training the driver and passenger get to
practice working together with one out
on the road signaling to the driver how
much room they have left to reverse the
instructors are always on hand with
useful tips
[Music]
not only helped me it didn't matter says
the instructor helped him this time but
hopefully if you're going off on holiday
you won't be alone and so you can ask
your passenger to guide you into parking
spaces that makes a huge difference in
fidi taking the training course is
especially useful for beginners to help
them get used to driving a vehicle of
this size and get a feel for the
dimensions
[Music]
well the light this participant says
she'll be getting a seven point eight
meter campervan so she wanted to be
prepared but the main focus is teaching
participants how to react in an
emergency those who appreciate both
their own and their vehicles limits will
drive more safely this participant says
she hasn't driven her camper van very
much so far she's learned a lot here
particularly how Breaking and reversing
into a parking space something she'd
never done before I'm pardon doesn't
sound his phone on your mascara today as
once again Sean matters how much he
doesn't know even though he drives every
day there are still many things he
overlooks in daily traffic and so it's
good to practice he'd recommend a road
safety course for every driver not just
those with camper vans mr. Frelinghuysen
will be listening so here fancy tights
trainings to do
you